[Música]
momentos más apasionantes en la historia
de la civilización un momento en el que
las tecnologías de la información y las
telecomunicaciones
tienen la enorme capacidad para liberar
masivas cantidades de bienestar
bienestar que denomino bienestar digital
y enormes cantidades y elementos que
denomino marginación y marginación que
también se considera marginación digital
vamos a hablar en los próximos minutos
del estado digital el estado digital
está integrado por distintos elementos
básicamente es afectado el estado como
lo conocemos hoy en día por elementos
que se denominan paradigmas los
paradigmas son creencias o hechos que se
presentan en la sociedad y que tiene la
enorme capacidad de alterar o modificar
las creencias pero particularmente el
marco jurídico la economía y de manera
muy visible a nuestra sociedad estos
paradigmas tienen nombres y
denominaciones que tú conoces
perfectamente bien y que te voy a
mencionar en este instante la
digitalización la enorme capacidad para
transportar toda la información en datos
que hoy en día son digitales el internet
esta maravilla de la tecnología que
desde hace más de 50 años viene
comunicándonos a todos de todas las
formas posibles la comunicación móvil
particularmente los smartphones que
antes no se llamaban smartphones y era
simplemente teléfono teléfonos móviles
que todos portamos por distintas partes
en nuestra casa domicilios y trabajo
también tiene que ver la banda ancha
está enorme capacidad para transportar
de forma masiva datos no es lo mismo que
el internet la convergencia la
convergencia y la enorme capacidad para
transportar información lineal o
segmentada a través de distintas
plataformas como lo es la satelital el
smrtv tu smartphone las para las
consolas de gamers e incluso
reproductores de blu-ray y tu
computadora de escritorio la
convergencia ha construido enormes
modelos de comunicación y de negocio hoy
en día tienes también el cómputo del
cómputo en 1965 el fundador de intel el
señor moore decía que cada dos años se
tendría la capacidad para el
procesamiento de datos esta ley de moore
por cierto muy pronto va a ser abatida
porque la capacidad de procesar datos y
de información ahora se da anualmente
tenemos también la nube mientras
hablamos mientras mediamos esta
comunicación entre tu pantalla y mi
comunicación tenemos al elefante en la
habitación todo proceso de
transformación digital y de comunicación
se da en la nube y tenemos también por
cierto a los nuevos agentes
disruptivos en paradigmáticos en el
universo digital me refiero al internet
de las cosas al big data y a la
inteligencia artificial a la capacidad
para identificar datos segmentar los
atraerlos analizarlos y después usarlos
a tiempo real a través de la
inteligencia artificial este es el mundo
de los nuevos paradigmas pero este mundo
de nuevos paradigmas y de la
conectividad presenta beneficios
inevitables cada mil conexiones de
internet generan 80 nuevos empleos cada
vez que crece 10 por ciento la
penetración de internet impacta en el
1.3 por ciento del pib incluso llegando
hasta el 3% en economías
pero también cada vez que crece el 10%
el ancho de banda
impacta en el punto 3% del pib estos son
algunos beneficios muy inmediatos que
podemos medir y todo esto se ha
comunicado a través de las generaciones
de tecnología móvil 1g 2g 3g 4g y ahora
5g 1 que fue la comunicación de voz del
teléfono que todos conocimos y que
solamente hablábamos por el 2 que el
mismo teléfono pero enviando mensajes
pequeños mensajes que se llamaron ese
mes es 3g ustedes recordarán que
hablábamos del mundo del blackberry el
mundo de la oficina móvil y el mundo
donde teníamos una enorme capacidad por
primera vez de gestionar nuestra
comunicación con el universo con el
mundo exterior en este mundo el gran
promotor de la tecnología 3g fue sin
duda barack obama que entró como
presidente de los eeuu con un blackberry
3g el mundo 3 que tenía 200 millones de
usuarios en facebook y en la mayor
cantidad de usuarios de creadores de
plataformas digitales
hoy en día tenemos a más de 3 mil
millones de usuarios por cada plataforma
cuando barack obama dejó la presidencia
de los eeuu empresas como facebook
tenían más de 2 mil millones de usuarios
y el último bien que se fue barack obama
de presidente de los eeuu estaba usando
un samsung 4g lte la capacidad
disruptiva de estas tecnologías era
extraordinaria
imagínense lo que puede suceder en un
universo 5g el mundo de las tecnologías
de la información se ha colapsado las
tics y las telecomunicaciones se han
fusionado en un universo donde todo es
digital los contenidos la propiedad
intelectual la radiodifusión las
telecomunicaciones y las tic las
fronteras han desaparecido con un solo
propósito tener a un ciudadano a una
ciudadana siempre conectado en todas
partes y gestionando su capacidad
creativa e intelectual ese es el único
propósito de la conectividad tener
conectado a alguien siempre en todas
partes y gestionar su capacidad de
conocimiento esto implica la creación de
nueva política pública no hay
herramienta más poderosa de
transformación social que el internet y
no hay herramienta más poderosa de
transformación hoy en día para el sector
público que la política digital la
política digital hoy en día tiene una
enorme capacidad es el gran igualador de
las condiciones económicas y sociales de
los individuos el internet las tics y el
universo digital y la política pública
digital tiene la capacidad justamente
para que hacer que una niña en la región
de la araucanía en una niña en el valle
del mezquital en el estado de hidalgo o
una niña en el en la región de iquitos
en perú tenga las mismas oportunidades
de educación y de acceso al conocimiento
y a la información que una niña
conectada a internet ya una computadora
en el lago leman de ginebra suiza
esta es la enorme oportunidad de nuestra
época pero además esta tecnología se han
presentado externalidades enormes yo
diría extraordinarias la primera de
ellas es que hay una innovación
constante la segunda las redes se han
transformado en mercados pero estos
mercados se han vuelto globales todo en
el mundo digital está evolucionando a
una velocidad vertiginosa pero además
existe también una atención inevitable
entre el mundo industrial y el mundo
digital entre el mundo de los viejos
modelos de la vieja economía y los
nuevos modelos de negocio de política
pública comunicación en un universo
digital es un mundo en constante y en
permanente choque y evolución uno de los
hijos más predilectos dos de los hijos
más predilectos del mundo digital son en
la era del acceso y la economía
colaborativa hoy en día las nuevas
generaciones ya no quieren la propiedad
de libros discos ni vídeos quieren
entrar a net netflix spotify ya kindle
ya no quieren tener la propiedad de un
automóvil quieren tener el acceso a ti a
volver a cabeza y estas plataformas ya
no quieren ir a la tienda y obtener los
productos y no quieren que se los lleven
hasta su propio domicilio la era del
acceso y la era de la economía
colaborativa y todo esto nos lleva
llevando a un momento estelar donde por
primera vez pudimos ver en la pandemia
que quien se mantuvo conectado quien
tuvo una conexión a internet y tuvo un
dispositivo móvil o una computadora
preservó el ejercicio de su libertad de
expresión su derecho de acceso a la
información y su derecho de acceso a la
salud a la educación pero al mismo
tiempo tuvo la capacidad para preservar
los indicadores económicos de su negocio
e incluso de su trabajo quien se mantuvo
conectado a internet fue más resiliente
a los efectos de la pandemia que quien
no estuvo conectado esta es una de las
características más importantes de la
sociedad digital la política digital
combate la pobreza más rápido que la
política pública tradicional punto el
impacto más inmediato que tenemos hoy en
día y el efecto que tendríamos que estar
esperando es la transformación digital
de la sociedad en su conjunto a partir
de la experiencia que nos ha dejado el
kobe pero además esto nos presenta un
nuevo estado algo que yo denomino estado
digital que libera bienestar digital
donde hay democracia digital donde hay
economía digital donde hay un conjunto
de elementos vitales para vivir mejor
que como diríamos antes en este mundo
que es el estado digital tiene que ver
con parte de la narrativa creativa y de
la lírica latinoamericana la parte
creativa que por ejemplo gabriel garcía
márquez nos narró cuando escribía en su
primera hoja de 100 años de soledad
que él veía y un mundo que era
profundamente reciente y que sucede en
el mundo digital decía garcía márquez
que el mundo era tan reciente que las
cosas carecían de nombre y para
mencionarlas había que señalar las con
la mano bienvenidos al estado digital
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]